it was a brutal murky murder in a pub
car park but was daniel morgan killed to
stop him exposing police corruption
today's report finds that police
corruption not only
hampered the investigation into his
murder it frustrated efforts to get to
the truth
for decades and that corruption remains
within the metropolitan police
34 years later concealing or denying
failings for the sake of an
organization's public image
is dishonesty on the part of the
organization
for reputational benefit this
constitutes
a form of institutional corruption
while the report discovered multiple
mistakes and misconduct such as
investigating officers drinking with
known suspects
it couldn't say whether corrupt police
were involved in the murder
but warned it was possible that local
officers involved in identified
lucrative corrupt practices such as
assisting criminals with inside police
information
thought that their police careers and
pensions were under threat
and the evidence supporting this theory
as to why daniel morgan was murdered
was never seriously investigated is the
metropolitan police force
institutionally corrupt
that's a phrase which of course has been
coined by this report so we need to
carefully consider the evidence upon
which that assertion is based but
my initial response of course is no
i believe in this organization the
report authors say the forces first
objective was to protect itself
even the panel struggled to get access
to police documents
and the family is owed an apology we
found ourselves lied to
fobbed off bullied degraded
and let down time and time again
what we were required to endure was
nothing less than torture
the metropolitan police commissioner who
today apologized
is under fire from daniel morgan's
family uh yes i do think she should be
considering that position
should she go uh yes certainly
it's a damning report it reveals sadly
significant corruption
but the woman who commissioned the
report as home secretary
defended cressida dick i've worked with
cressida dick both as home secretary
and as prime minister she is an
extraordinarily able police officer
the home secretary has asked her to
respond to this report
and i'm sure that's exactly what she
will want to do
the gruesome attack in an isolated car
park has resulted
in five investigations costing an
estimated
30 million pounds multiple arrests
but not a single conviction so let's
look at the timeline
in march 1987 the body of private
investigator daniel morgan is found with
an axe embedded in his head at the
golden lion pub in sydney
he's killed shortly after meeting his
business partner jonathan reese for a
drink
a month later six people are arrested on
suspicion of murder
they include mr reese and sid fillery a
metropolitan police detective originally
assigned
to the case all are released without
charge and there are four more
investigations over the years involving
the bugging of suspects homes
as well as the offices of mr reese in
2008
four men are charged with daniel
morgan's murder
including jonathan reece but three years
later at the old bailey the case against
the men collapsed jonathan reese and sid
fillery
who've throughout maintained their
innocence go on to win damages for
malicious prosecution
the metropolitan police made a litany of
mistakes
and that this irreparably damaged the
chances of successful prosecution
this is one of the most devastating
episodes in the history of the
metropolitan police
some suggestions in this 1200 page
report
point to reopening the case but it does
say crucial evidence has almost
certainly been lost jason farrell sky
news